thank that thin privilege is a real
thing go around no it's not a real thing
all the things she listed as thin
privilege they're just things that come
with the fact that you're thin it's not
necessarily a privilege if you're fat of
course you know there's certain Health
complications are going to come so of
course the doctor's going to blame
anything on that your BMI is going to be
over 30 so that's not a thing that you
don't get because you're you've got thin
privilege it's just the fact
is is there an echo there's the comments
are saying there's an echo I think there
was an echo on the on the video okay
okay that's fine then
um
what do you think yeah I don't I
wouldn't say there's anything such as uh
thin privilege but
there are as he said the ways people
address you speak to you when you're
when you look maybe extremely different
yeah like when you have a certain size
on an airplane you know like she was
saying
um but yeah it's it's not necessarily a
privilege it's just I think Society
letting you know
um when you're too big you know
that's not the way to go I just think
that's what it is
um I disagree I do think there is such a
thing as thin privilege because it's not
just about the extremes of being
particularly large you can be still like
a relatively healthy weight but like
slightly bigger and you will definitely
be treated differently like I I know of
people who are maybe like a size 14 16
and a friend of mine like returned an
item and the person who was serving her
said well I think this might not have
been your size like you're bigger than
that
was she squeezing no she just was
returning it because she didn't like the
item
and and to say it was a poor fit that
doesn't necessarily mean that you don't
fit into that size but as I'm sure we've
probably all experienced
everywhere that you shop and every
garment that you buy
is a is a completely different size like
every retailer Works to a different
um that's true sizing profile so that is
an example to me of of thin privilege
but if I go to a shop and I buy a shirt
and my friends told me oh that looks too
small on you you should have gone a
different size
like what what does that mean it doesn't
mean that you know no that's different
and people are saying it doesn't it
doesn't fit you all you should it might
not fit you in this particular
circumstance that was
a sales advisor saying that to somebody
who's returning an item that's different
to trying something on and your friends
saying oh that's a bit tight on you
but it just it's just advice isn't it
like that might be too small for you
she's just trying to help help out yeah
it is their job I've been a sales
assistant you know you kind of have to
tell people does this fit you does this
look good on you so fair enough she was
returning it and as a salesperson she
was probably trying to convince her to
get a different size oh maybe you might
like it then I don't think it's anything
to do with oh that's phobia because
it's just it could just be a fact that
it might look better on you if you try a
different size because when I hear the
word privilege I think of something that
like you're born with but you
know like it's inherently yeah like like
because one one thing that I often hear
is White Privilege right and so that's
something that's something you're born
with
right but but fat privilege or fat or
thin privilege is a choice
thin privilege isn't a thing if I'm if I
that's my opinion I don't think it's a
thing I think we need to look at the
root you know definition of the word
privilege when I think of privilege I
think something
or a treatment you are afforded
um because of a specific attribute that
you possess so I don't necessarily
believe it has to be something that
you're
um born with I think that's the context
is we began to use the word privilege
like white privilege and sin privilege
and things like that it gives the
impression that it's something that
you're born with and can't change but we
have to look at the root definition of
privilege and I think that's what it is
things that you're afforded because of a
certain characteristic or maybe not
having a characteristic a factor that
you possess whether subconsciously or
consciously theme privilege is not a
thing I don't think it's a thing I don't
think it's anything oh I think
especially going back to that Tick Tock
a lot of the things that she said that
she doesn't experience because of the
nature of the body shape that she has
are just standard things other standard
things I don't think thing privilege is
a thing I think if we look at the other
end of the extreme
you know like bigger people that's when
we can start maybe using some of those
words but I don't think I improve is the
thing I'm borderline thin in certain
say cultures or beauty standards and I
don't think it affords me anything more
in my
daily life I don't think yeah
so pretty privilege is a yeah that's
what I was gonna say I would say pretty
privilege is a thing I mean even though
yeah even the comments they're talking
about you so go ahead go ahead I think I
think privilege how I would Define
privilege is an unearned Advantage for
peripheral treatment
so like
so white privilege yeah you're born with
that so it's kind of like
the the prefer the peripheral treatment
you get is an unearned Advantage because
you haven't worked for that peripheral
treatment right but thin privilege if
you're slim that's you've earned that so
it's not it's not privilege
um
you you
ate less than other women maybe attained
is the right word I was gonna say I do
disagree with your definition of
privilege just because you know if
you're rich there's certain preferential
treatment you get from people but you
worked hard to become rich yeah so and
so I think it was rich privilege though
I think there is yes there are certain
things afforded to you because you are
rich people drink differently because
you are rich that's true
if anything money is equalizer so I was
asking reduce who would you say somebody
is more privileged if they started from
nothing and became rich or somebody in
inherited that richness I don't think
there's any because I could be born poor
and then become a billionaire I'll be
very privileged so I don't think it has
anything to do with that I would say
that I changed my stance there might be
such a thing as thing privilege but I
don't think it's a bad thing can I ask
what made you change your stance because
I'm thinking about it you know based on
the different initially I was thinking
the definition privilege as something
that you
character that you're characterized as
inherently and it gives you an advantage
in life but then now I'm thinking of you
know you can work hard and become rich
and become privileged because of it so I
don't think it's necessarily something
that's inherent to you but when I hear
privilege I just think of something
you're like born like when I hear Rich
privilege I don't think of someone that
was broke and became rich I think of
someone that was born rich yeah I get
that but I think it does being rich does
give you a certain privilege but no
matter how hard you worked for it but
when you say privilege like I think of
something you didn't earn yeah what's
that what's the difference between
gaining privilege because you got to a
certain position and then gaining the
perks that come with that position
so
what's what's the difference
right so like for example like if you
say for example oh
um you you become the unknown let's say
you become a pilot right which means
that part of your privilege as a pilot
is you don't have to go through security
when you travel right okay is that a
privilege or is that a perk that you
gained from getting that position oh I
see the difference because if you think
the comparison Park you can kind of say
that being fat is a privilege now
because of as a fat person you get a
privilege of calling people fat phobic
foreign